New York City has just erected a golden
demon statue on top of a courthouse near
Madison Square Park and when I say a
golden demon statue I'm not being
hyperbolic or funny
it is a gold statue of a demon woman
with horns on her head and weird
tentacle things for arms dedicated to
Ruth Bader Ginsburg and specifically to
ginsburg's support for abortion the
artist who made it told the New York
Times that the statue is part of a quote
urgent and necessary cultural Reckoning
underway as New York reconsiders
traditional representations of power in
public spaces and recast Civic
structures to better reflect 21st
century mores
you see in Old New York we placed on top
of our courthouses Stone and Marble
statues of famous law givers
allegories such as Lady Justice
because our old social mores reflected
reverence for things like Law And
Justice today we erect golden demon
Idols to the human sacrifice of little
babies
because our social mores reflect
reverence for things such as Hedonism
and selfishness the libs and the artists
see this as a wonderful thing
the horns on the Beast are according to
the reports meant to symbolize autonomy
and sovereignty nice enough sounding
values and at least until you think
about what they really mean
but that is how it always goes
I am sure that the ancient Canaanites
thought themselves perfectly justified
in worshiping Baal I have no doubt that
the ancient Assyrians thought that it
was a wonderful fine thing to sacrifice
their babies to moloch we look back on
those ancient practices the idol worship
the human sacrifice and we all mock it
as absurd we're we're horrified at it
even though we today do precisely in
every single aspect
the same exact thing
the Israelites themselves about five
seconds after Moses walked up the
mountain to talk to God decided to
betray The God Who led them out of Egypt
and worship a golden calf so what do we
do now
the squishes will tell us
we need to respect the Demonic artists
we need to tolerate their alleged
freedom of demon worship or whatever
their their imaginary right to erect
satanic statutes but I for one hope that
the next Republican mayor of New York
Whoever has power to get rid of this
thing
acts a little less like an anything goes
you do you who am I to judge art let's
leave it all alone man kind of
politician and acts a little bit more
like Moses after he came down the
mountain and I hope that that future
Republican politician not only removes
this monstrosity but smashes it up to
Smithereens in public that would send an
artistic political and religious message
from which we all stand to benefit I'm
Michael knows this the Michael Knowles
show
foreign
[Music]
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Joe Bag of Donuts what a name who says
if you have shellfish allergies you
should not eat z-bugs and the food
should come with a warning label that is
true if you have shellfish allergies you
definitely should avoid eating some bugs
also if you don't have shellfish
allergies you should also avoid eating
as a bugs eating the bugs is not not a
great thing I
it's just undignified it's just taboo it
just doesn't go along with our culture
and you make a good point if you have an
allergy I guess it could kill you you
will die someday though that's why you
got to check out epic will right now
head on over to epicwill.com use promo
code nulls it can be tough to stick to
your New Year's resolutions you set out
with lofty goals you stick to them for
two weeks then you fall right back into
your old habits lucky for you I've got a
goal that you can accomplish today
complete your will with epic will for
just 119 bucks and in as little as five
minutes epic will can help you create
your last will and testament living will
and even Healthcare power of attorney
their step-by-step online form makes it
all incredibly easy all you need to do
is fill in the blanks I did not have a
will for a long time that was very very
irresponsible of me I sleep much easier
at night now that I do because if you
don't have a will you don't know what's
going to happen to your money and your
stuff and most importantly your kids do
the responsible thing right now it's
super quick it's super inexpensive 50 of
Americans don't have a will choose today
to be in the smarter half go to
epicwell.com use promo code null save 10
percent on Epic Will's complete will
package that is epic will
e-p-i-c-w-i-l-l.com
o code Knowles Canada w-l-e-s
speaking of demon ladies
there's a new bill going around the
Senate called the Pelosi Act
I really love this bill this was
proposed by Senator Josh Hawley
this is a bill that he had previously
introduced so now he's retooled it a
little bit and renamed it it would uh
ban insider trading I mean insider
trading is already banned but it would
specifically ban lawmakers and their
spouses from holding and trading
individual stocks and would force
political figures to return profits to
the American citizens and it is called
the preventing elected leaders from
owning Securities and Investments Act
also known as the Pelosi Act and the
reason for this is that for whatever
reason Washington politicians have this
weird habit of outperforming the stock
market
that kind of strange these Washington
politicians they're not necessarily
accomplished investment professionals
they don't have advanced degrees and
awards and finance and but for some
whatever reason these guys in DC tend to
outperform the stock market
earlier this month Business Insider
reported at least 78 members of Congress
both Democrats and Republicans had
violated a 2012 law known as the stock
act the stop trading on Congressional
knowledge act and uh and uh so now Holly
is trying to clamp down on that
because that's what happens that's how
corruption works these insiders in DC
get all sorts of information that you
are not privy to that your financial
advisor if you have one is not privy to
they get all that info and then they
trade stocks based on that and then they
make a bunch of money
and it's just it's so
basically corrupt it's not even corrupt
in one of these really House of Cards
kind of Palace Intrigue ways it's just
it's just politicians using secret info
to make a couple of bucks
speaking of secret info our friends over
at project Veritas have a huge story
project Veritas does incredible
journalistic work because they come out
with so many of these investigations
some are bigger Bombshells than others
this is the biggest project very tough
story I have seen in quite a while this
project very tough Story shows a Pfizer
executive confiding some secret
information with someone with whom he
thinks he is on a date
that Pfizer is planning gain of function
research on the Coronavirus
Pfizer ultimately is thinking about
mutating covet well that's not what we
say to the public no don't tell anyone
yeah
first story like no you know the virus
keeps mutating yeah well one of the
things we're saying is like why don't we
just mutate it ourselves
new vaccines right so we have to do that
if we're going to do that though there's
a risk of like as you could imagine no
one wants to be having a farmer company
mutating feeling very controlled
to make sure that this virus that you
mutate it doesn't create something like
you know it goes everywhere yeah you got
to be really controlled and really good
at working with covid and really precise
on your vaccines so you know look I know
that we at Pfizer specifically and the
entire Public Health establishment
broadly have gotten every single thing
wrong about covid but we'll probably get
it right this time let's start messing
around with the viruses huh let's start
beefing them up what could go wrong
that's not some conspiracy theory
that's not that's a director of research
specifically working on mRNA vaccines at
Pfizer
and he's saying yeah look we don't tell
the public this
because you know what the fact check is
going to be
the fact check from the AP or Reuters or
PolitiFact or any of these ostensibly
neutral journalist Outlets they're going
to say well
no Pfizer has been very clear that they
don't do this and then you got this guy
this director of research coming in and
saying yeah I know that's what we say
we're lying
we are working on this
and of course they are of course they
are do you remember when Dr fauci went
up onto Capitol Hill and and Rand Paul
grilled him and said you were conducting
gain of function research you're you
were funding it and what did fauci say
he says send editable
we have we have never
funded or conducted this kind of gain of
function research
and then my favorite part was was the
way he concluded his denial is it and if
we did it was totally fine because
because Rand Paul had the goods and so
fauci perjures himself before the U.S
Senate Rand Paul says actually you
funded this doctor you gave him this
grant that Grant went to this place and
you conducted again to function research
and fauci looked like a deer in the
headlights he goes well no we didn't we
never did that it is totally fake and
even if it's real it's fine don't worry
let's move on pay no attention to the
man behind the curtain
because they're Liars that's why we
don't believe them anymore that's why we
don't trust them that's why it it is
unreasonable for most people to get the
vaccine and always has been the reason
it has always been unreasonable for most
people to get the vaccine is because the
people peddling the vaccine are known
Liars with no credibility
and you're seeing this now with Pfizer
this guy bragging to the person he
thinks he's on a date with
so yeah we're still lying to the public
we haven't we've learned absolutely no
lesson we know that we are completely
immune from any consequences so yeah
we're gonna lie and then we're gonna
mess around and we're going to engage in
the same kind of research that almost
certainly caused the pandemic in the
first place what do we do about this
here's the fork in the road guys this is
the fork in the road for conservatives
you've got the squishes
who might be tempted to say well
you know it's a private company it's a
pro we can't interfere in the operations
of the free market we don't want big
government to come in and tell Pfizer
What to do no no that would be terrible
that would be that's the real risk that
we Face here so look if you don't like
these these uh big pharmaceutical
Executives uh messing around with very
dangerous viruses and potentially
shutting the world down again for three
years we'll just build your own Pfizer
that's the that's one fact then the
other path is
wield the government to smush this
company into the ground wheeled the
government in as much as we can because
there's a lot of regulatory capture by
big Pharma but wield the government to
stop this that's the fork in the road
which way conservative man
you know my friend Senator Cruz
has the right instincts on these sorts
of questions Senator Cruz just
introduced a bill
into the Senate that I think is so so
important not just for the issue that it
seems to directly address but for for
the broader way that we should be
thinking about Washington DC
uh Senator Cruz introduced a bill to
stop illegal aliens from voting in
Washington D.C both illegal aliens and
people who are here on let's say green
cards or visas but they're not citizens
all non-citizens should not get to vote
in Washington D.C
Senator Cruz says allowing non-citizens
including aliens occupying our nation
illegally to exercise a right reserve
for American citizens not only violates
the constitutional principles our nation
was founded upon but also naively
invites foreign meddling in our
elections totally true
but this is not only happening in D.C
this is happening in San Francisco this
there was a proposal to do this in New
York all around the country in the
liberal cities
there is a movement to let non-citizens
start voting and they may have the right
to do that within their own
municipalities
San Francisco because of federalism may
have the right certain school boards may
have the right to let non-citizens vote
so what makes Washington DC different
this is this is really the core of this
issue I think
Washington DC is the federal district
ultimately Congress is responsible for
Washington D.C
the Congress chose to allow Washington
DC to have its own mayor to have its own
representatives to have its own local
government
but Washington DC is not a state
Washington DC is not a normal town like
any other just by no stretch of the
imagination is Washington DC a normal
town and the the the
Congress has simply given Washington DC
too much local power you always see this
on license plates in DC it's this
taxation without representation you see
this move in Washington D.C to turn the
federal district into a new state it
deserves to be a state no the whole
point of Washington DC is that it's not
a state the whole point of Washington DC
is that it is not a local government it
is the national government it's that's
why we have the capital of our country
in that federal district so that no one
state has the capital right there
we've given them too much power
the Washington DC is always run by Libs
they always vote Democrat and we should
stop that the Congress should exert much
much more control this is going to be
another one of those issues that maybe
splits the conservatives because you're
you're going to hear from some of the
squishes well no we don't big government
bad national government bad we need more
local control representation if you're
going to have Taxation and this is
perfect even if they always vote for
Democrats even if they allow illegal
aliens to vote that's their right it's
no
we need
big government
the biggest government we got the
national government to come in and run
Washington D.C that's not my new modern
liberal statist opinion that's how
Washington DC was founded that's
explicitly what DC was founded for
and we cannot trust the local government
it's one of the most corrupt local
governments in the country
now
speaking of who gets to go to Washington
D.C
within the next year or two
good news for president Trump coming out
of the 2024 primary polls there's a new
poll out for morning consult
shows that President Trump
has the support of nearly half of the
GOP he's got 49 support
number two we all know who number two is
is Ron DeSantis uh Miranda Santos has 30
support which is very very impressive
but it's still 19 points behind Trump
and then no one else comes close
Mike Pence has seven percent Nikki Haley
has three percent Senator Cruz has two
percent
and then other people are barely even
registering
the reason this matters is not not
because General primary polls are that
big a deal
not because we're getting all that close
to the actual primaries lack of change
in the meantime
the reason this matters is the momentum
Trump has regained ground in the GOP
Trump before the midterms even before he
announced his his run in 2024
he was the dominant force in the GOP
many people thought that if he ran for
president he would just clear the field
then
he just kind of started falling down a
little bit he made some missteps and the
midterms didn't turn out as well as he
and others were hoping and Ron DeSantis
just is Pitch Perfect every single week
he gets a great new headline he looks
good he's growing in favor with GOP
Primary voters and so there was this
fear in Trump World I'm certain that
those trend lines were just going to
keep continuing and Trump would
disappear and and Ron DeSantis would be
would become The Heir Apparent that does
not seem to be happening Miranda Santos
could easily still become the GOP
nominee in 2024 but Trump's 19 point
lead right now is up from
only an 11 point lead which he had
earlier this month
at that time Trump had 45 percent to
desantises 34 percent now he's gaining
ground all of which is to say people
think that they know the future people
think that every discrete moment that
we're living in is eternity and that
right now the way the headlines and the
polls look that is going to be how
things are forever but of course in
politics things are changing constantly
and it's a reminder that DeSantis is
doing everything right
and there are other candidates who are
throwing their hats in the Rings even
after they had suggested they might not
people like Nikki Haley Tim Scott
appears to be preparing a presidential
run lots of people who are getting
involved
this is still Trump's race to lose Trump
is still the dominant force in the race
even
those of us who have our nose nose in
politics all the time people who are
listening to this show right now are
much much better informed on politics
than at least 96 of the country probably
more than that if you're listening to
this show you have a political interest
you stay up to date on what's going on
you you have some understanding of the
political philosophy undergirding not
only these movements in politics but the
candidates as well that is not true for
most of the country
for most of the country they just they
just know Trump they remember Trump
because he's been a celebrity for 40
years and they know that he was the
president I bet you a huge number of
Americans if not most Americans couldn't
tell you who the vice president is or
sir or certainly not couldn't tell you
very much about who the vice president
is it is still Trump's race to lose
speaking of vice presidents
there's more classified documents
everybody has classified documents
classified documents were found at Mike
Pence's house I think it was actually
Mike Pence or one of his lawyers who
found them this after classified
documents were found at Biden's house
this after classified documents were
found at Trump's house I am
I'm quite certain the last
political figure in the United States
to not have classified documents in my
house and I don't know maybe I do maybe
I don't I don't know how I would have
gotten them but they're cropping up
everywhere
including at Mike Pence's house so what
does this mean
it's eliciting
very very interesting responses
starts with Trump they find the
classified docs this is the end of the
world this is going to cause nuclear war
they sold sold State secrets we got a
raid Mar-A-Lago we got to send in the
Jack booted thugs knock down the
president's door oh we got to get those
docs this is a horrible now we got to
prosecute Trump
then they find documents at Biden's
office oh okay now it's not as big a
deal no it's fine no I'd haven't
classified documents no forget about it
and if Biden just did it once it was at
his office oh I was at his house too hmm
well I'm sure it was really secure oh it
was actually next to his Corvette that
is degenerate corrupt sun was driving oh
oh well and he didn't even the president
has a right to declassify whatever he
wants but Biden took those docs from his
vice president doesn't never right to do
that okay all right well yeah it's not a
big deal let's forget about talking
about the Trump thing for a while oh but
Pence did it okay good all right now
it's a big deal again
now it's a big deal because it's two
Republicans did it it's only one it's
only one Democrat it's a big deal
it's a really really big deal
and Trump responds to this
and Trump has had a little bit of a
contentious relationship with Mike Pence
in recent years because he wanted Mike
Pence to refuse to certify the election
and he attacked Mike Pence after Pence
wouldn't do that
but Trump says quote
Mike Pence is an innocent man he never
did anything knowingly dishonest in his
life leave him alone three exclamation
marks
huh
and as with all Trump tweets and
comments and you think
is he is this ironic is it is he Earnest
is
I I think it's earnest
he goes on he says they created this
documents mess for themselves by being
so totally deranged about me
and I did nothing wrong
so Trump's saying it's all about me
they're just trying to get me
stop going after pens come on the guy's
like the most honest guy in the world
now Pence after Trump's home was rated
in August Pence said I've not hesitated
to criticize the president when I think
he was wrong and clearly possessing
classified documents in an unprotected
area is not proper
so now you've got Trump being especially
magnanimous
after pens with with some Good Reason by
the way if I were pins I'd be probably
pretty miffed it at Trump as well
but Pence doesn't defend Trump on the
classified documents Trump does defend
Pence to me this reads as sincere though
it is helpful to trump it shows that
Trump was right in the first place
about all this classified documents
non-traversing and it does something
that I think really will help Trump and
will help to increase his poll numbers
which is it makes Trump look much more
loyal loyal than other people in
politics and loyal than he previously
had been and this is a quality that
people love about Trump and it's it's
not talked about very much but Donald
Trump
has been for a lot of his career
extremely loyal to the people that he is
close to and that started to break down
and the constant focus on the slights
against him especially in the last
couple of years I think has turned a lot
of people off and felt like a very
Turning Away of the focus
but
people really like this quality that
Trump will defend his guys and
ultimately that Trump will defend you
it's like that that Meme that he posted
during the campaign
Hillary says I'm with her he says I'm
with you I mean it changes the subject
and the object of that slogan Trump says
they're not coming after me they're
coming after you I just happen to be in
the way that's that connection that
Trump has and I think this looks really
really good for him
the way that I know that I'm right about
how to interpret the Pence classified
documents nontroversy is that Joy Behar
on The View told me that I'm right
you know the one thing about this that I
think is good is when it was just Biden
and Trump I thought well maybe Merrick
Garland and the special prosecutor will
feel like it's politically motivated to
go after Trump now you know because you
got to watch the politics now they don't
have to worry about that that's because
they've got now they've got you know two
misery loves company well yeah it's not
politically there's more misery to come
now it's not politically motivated
that's the best part as she describes
the most cynical
opportunistic political motivation for a
prosecution oh I think this is great I'm
glad that that
uh Mike Pence had those documents this
is terrific
well hold on the argument for why you're
going to go after Trump on the
classified documents is that mishandling
classified documents is a very serious
very dangerous crime
right that's the only reason that you're
going to go after him on it
but then Biden did the same thing he
actually did a worse version of the same
thing and you let it go
then Mike Pence did the same thing and
now you're saying okay this is good we
can go after Trump again oh Graham's so
pleased but if the crime the alleged
crime itself were so serious
then you wouldn't be happy that it's
happening again if it really posed a
danger to National Security you'd say oh
my gosh three in a row we're gonna die
here man this is terrible I'm sure the
Chinese and the Saudis and the I don't
know whoever else
I'm sure they got this information this
is terrible no
no it's totally fake no one is actually
worried at all
about these classified documents sitting
in a closet somewhere
when anyone does it it's pure political
opportunism
Joy Behar has no respect for our
Democratic norms
are you know there are sacred Democratic
Norms that the libs always talk about
just says oh good okay two versus one
great let's go after Trump
speaking of no respect for our
Democratic Norms Adam Schiff
you know Adam Schiff
is the guy who lied to you or at least
was completely wrong and dishonest about
the entire Trump presidency he's got
really swampy ties to the Deep State he
said a lot of things that weren't true
that
exacerbated the impeachment process for
Trump one of the impeachment processes
for Trump he's just he's one of the
worst out there and so McCarthy removed
him from the intelligence committee
because
Adam Schiff abused his power
well Adam Schiff has not going down
without a fight he says
Kevin McCarthy just kicked me and Eric
swalwell off the intelligence committee
Eric swalwell who allegedly slept with a
Chinese spy
this is petty political payback for
investigating Donald Trump if he thinks
this will stop me he will soon find out
just how wrong he is I will always
defend our democracy
our democracy is what kicked Adam Schiff
off the committee in the first place
what what does the phrase our democracy
mean in the sentence that Adam Schiff
posted
Adam Schiff was kicked off the
intelligence committee by Kevin McCarthy
who was elected speaker of the house by
the members of Congress
who were elected by the people in our
democracy
Adam Schiff being kicked off this
committee is a
fairly Direct
consequence
of our democracy
but our democracy as the libs use that
phrase
does not really mean democracy sometimes
people correct me when I when I use this
phrase even when I use this phrase as I
am right now in jest they say Michael
we're a democracy we're a republic not a
democracy which is fair enough and you
see the framers of the Constitution make
this distinction in The Federalist
Papers but what's confusing about it is
that in the Federalist the civilizations
that they refer to as democracies really
were republics and the ones they
referred to as republics really were
democracies and it's a little difficult
to neatly separate those two things but
regardless let's let's say we were a
democracy the libs don't care at all
about democracy
for the libs and I don't think they're
doing this in any nefarious way I don't
think they're particularly educated or
intelligent enough to be using that this
the word in this nefarious intentional
way
they I think they genuinely believe
that democracy is synonymous with
liberalism
that's not people the Democracy can
elect right-wing governments just the
same as they can elect the libs
that's what happened in Hungary with
Victor Urbana that's what happened in
Italy with Georgia Maloney
that's what happened in that's what
happened in the UK with the brexit
that's what happened in America with
Trump
and they just can't accept that
so whenever that happens whenever the
people elect a conservative they say
this is an attack on our democracy which
is obviously incoherent that's a uh
internally a contradiction if you were
to say that but it's just because they
they mean by democracy liberalism and so
anytime liberalism fails
they they say it's illegitimate so what
Adam Schiff is saying is I will defend
liberalism
I will defend liberalism
to the very end
even if the people want me gone I will
defend liberalism because the the
representatives of liberalism the
expression of liberalism is the Deep
state is the swamp is that the blob
liberal establishment that frequently
tries to undermine the will of the
American people within the confines of
the US Constitution who the people who
are operating within the confines of the
US Constitution The Blob deep State
liberal establishment that very often is
not now there is
some good news coming out of the deep
State I I want to be as Fair as I can to
those swampy blob monsters over in DC
the Department of Justice has just sued
Google
for having a monopoly over digital ads
the doj and several State Attorneys
General filed a suit against Google on
Tuesday for allegedly monopolizing
digital ad Technologies quote today's
complaint alleges that Google has used
anti-competitive exclusionary and
unlawful conduct to eliminate or
severely diminish any threat to its
dominance over digital ad Technologies
the doj will vigorously enforce our
antitrust laws to protect consumers
Safeguard competition and ensure
economic fairness and opportunity for
all
here we arrive at another fork in the
road conservatives
which way are you going to go
the squishes
are going to say well I don't know I
mean yeah I don't like Google you know
because Google controls roughly 90 of
the flow of information in our country
and it's tilted entirely to the left and
they censor conservatives and
block conservatives from campaigning and
rig the search results to promote
liberal uh causes and
but at least it's not big government I
don't know
I don't know this Google that's that
Google's a private company
if you don't like the way that Google is
completely restructuring our political
order in our Republic
well you know just build your own Google
and then you got the conservatives
who who will say
no
no if if my speech is being taken away
if my ability to govern myself and to
elect representatives who really
represent me as being taken away if my
access to information real information
about even politically controversial
subjects like vaccines or the
coronavirus or immigration or any other
number of issues is being taken away I
don't care
if it's being taken away by the
government or by an allegedly private
Corporation I just want to protect my
rights I just want to protect my way of
life
so if it's the government going after me
then I'll go after the government if
it's a private Corporation going after
me I'll go after a private Corporation
and it's not a private Corporation by
the way Google was
built with a lot of support from the
government and Google maintains its
dominance with a lot of support from the
government and from from the federal
agencies
and in fact the the way that the elite
liberals who want to take over the world
and make us all eatsy bugs and
Livingston pods and own nothing and be
happy the way that they want to do that
is not simply through
communism or it's not simply through
growing the government into a more
Progressive entity what they tell you
what the Davos crowd the world economic
Forum the elite liberals who have a lot
of power what they tell you is they want
to do it through public private
Partnerships
it's actually still today very hard for
the libs to censor you outright through
the government the First Amendment
stands in the way
It's Tricky
but it's not so hard for the libs to use
the government to pressure the allegedly
private corporations to do the
government's dirty work for it that's
what happened when they booted Trump off
all the platforms that's what happened
when they when when the FBI and the doj
pressured big tech companies to suppress
the hunter Biden laptop story
effectively too
that that's very bad too
so which is it are we going to be the
little are we going to be the little
squishes
are we going to be the big bull mooses
here what are we going to do we're going
to are we going to have the guts to take
on big Power monopolistic power wherever
it resides as Teddy Roosevelt told us to
do as Barry Goldwater told us to do for
goodness sakes
or are we going to be little squishes
are we going to be Court gestures in the
Kingdom of liberalism and say well you
know if we're if we're excuse me if
we're really big principled
conservatives that the way to be
principled is to let a gigantic woke
corporations completely destroy our way
of life no I don't think so I don't
think so
even more good news coming out of the
swamps we were talking about the
classified documents Scandal before
the feds have rated Joe Biden's Home
Federal officials searched Biden's home
in Wilmington Delaware
they discovered even more classified
material than previously had turned up
at one of his offices at his fake think
tank that had been funded with Chinese
money and at his home they found even
more classified documents doj took
possession of materials it deemed within
the scope of its inquiry including six
items consisting of documents with
classification markings and surrounding
materials some of which were from the
president's service in the Senate and
some of which were from his tenure as VP
that's according to Biden's personal
lawyer
so hold on now it's not even just from
the Obama years now goes all the way
back to when he was a Senator Biden
hasn't been a senator since what 2008
it goes back a very very long time it it
probably won't amount to much of
anything but I suspect the reason that
they conducted this rate is they had to
it would have looked so transparently
corrupt had they had they not done it
because they did the same thing to Trump
and so what you have here I think is
what La Roche Foucault described as uh
uh hypocrisy
being the tribute that Vice pays to
Virtue these are vicious corrupt people
running our government
but they I think they they sort of
recognized here it was so it would look
so transparent if they didn't if they
didn't raid by his own it almost
certainly won't amount to anything
but at least at least it is an
acknowledgment the very fact that the
the doj the FBI raided the home
is an acknowledgment that these are the
same things and whatever you want to
accuse Trump of doing you can accuse
Biden of doing tenfold that's always
whatever you want to accuse Republicans
are doing
you can accuse the Democrats of doing
tenfold yesterday I told you how we are
all one step closer to eating zibags the
EU officially enacted a statute to allow
those food producers to incorporate
Cricket powder into flower-based
products
not because it tastes better not because
we've developed a new refined palette
for insects but because the political
Elites have deemed that it's it's better
for the environment
and they can make a lot of money doing
it so right down to the foods you eat
the world wants to make you woke but not
Dennis Prager he wants to make you wise
and the founder of prageru is going to
do just that with a never-before-seen
series exclusively on daily wire plus
called The Master's program with Dennis
Prager we at the daily wire have a
long-standing friendship with Dennis
going back many many years
one of my absolute favorite cigar
buddies in all of Los Angeles uh you may
have seen my book club over on prageru
you might have seen one of Prairie's
famous five-minute videos I've done a
bunch of those as well in fact prageru
Alan Esther and the executive director
of prageru gave me the idea for my book
speechless controlling words controlling
mine so I you know I just obviously love
Prager you love Dennis Prager he's got a
wealth of experience and what the
master's program aims to do is take 40
Years of wisdom and experience from one
of the most influential conservative
thinkers in America and distill it all
down to its Essence he covers topics
such as the consequences of secularism
is human nature basically good it's a
thought-provoking and Illuminating work
the first two episodes of Prager use
master's program are available to stream
right now exclusively on daily wire plus
head on over to dailywordplus.com become
a member and watch prageru Masters
program and more that's
dailywireplus.com
[Music]
speaking of raids Dave Chappelle is
being raided and attacked by transgender
activists here he explains
so I get to the show that night and of
course protesters came uh what a thing
mayor you wouldn't believe it these were
grown people of various genders and
gender identities they threw eggs they
threw eggs that the people were lined up
to see the show oh yeah they was doing
all that one lady was so mad with the
protesters she picked up a police
barricade they never seen it looked like
a bike rack just picked that barricade
up by herself
and threw it at the crowd I got to tell
you it's an amazing feat of strength for
a woman
so it really sounds like an an exciting
scene as Chappelle goes on he says
trying to silence a person like me I
don't think it has anything to do with
being loved they want to be feared if
you say this then we will punish you
we'll come to First Avenue and F your
show up and we'll come to The Varsity
Theater and F your show up and they just
don't get to do that
Dave's describing this Behavior he says
man this is a crazy behavior
why are they doing this he says he's
trying to think of it really rationally
he says well they're doing because they
want Power I'm sure that's true and
they're doing because they want to
intimidate me and shut me up yeah I'm
sure that's true you know why else
they're doing it do you know why else
these transgender activists are behaving
like crazy people in public
because they're they're easy people
sometimes the simplest answer really is
the best and the most persuasive
these are very very crazy people if you
are a man and you think that you're a
woman you're a you're a very crazy
person and you need psychological help I
know I'm not saying that to be mean to
anybody or to make anybody feel small or
belittled but you have serious problems
if you think that and you need to go get
help
because if you don't get help if you
indulge these delusions you're just
gonna act crazier and crazier
so what do we do about this
what do we do about crazy people
generally you know the the Britney
Spears conservatorship
was a real Illuminating incident
on this kind of a question
because
we didn't know exactly how to react we
also didn't have perfect information is
Britney Spears really having
psychological problems is she totally
fine and she's just being kept a
prisoner because of her corrupt and
greedy father or that we we didn't
really quite know
but there was there was an even deeper
question which is well let's say she is
kind of crazy she should she really be
under a conservatorship or should she be
free to act as crazy as she wants
we've come to another fork in the road
here
which way are you going to go
the the squishes and the libs and our
society for the last 50 years has said
hey if you're crazy and you're in deep
distress and you have trouble
functioning in society and you can't
really take care of yourself and
that's your problem
you still have a right
to do whatever you want to do you want
to go dance around throwing eggs in the
air at a Dave Chappelle show that's
totally fine you want to go live on the
street and do a bunch of drugs down on
Skid Row that's totally fine you want to
have public meltdowns everywhere that's
your right to do it because of your
bodily sovereignty and autonomy and
self-ownership or whatever
but the conservative response is no if
if you are not in possession of your
rational faculties if you do not have a
properly functioning rational will
then not only do you not have a right to
be left alone and do whatever you want
you don't have the capacity to do that
you don't have the ability to do that
you see this in the in the big divide
over insane asylums
for
pretty much all of world history we had
insane asylums for people who were
too crazy to take care of themselves
then in the middle of the 20th century
we decided to close down all the insane
asylums
and we did that probably with good
intention because they're not
particularly Pleasant places because
mental illness is deeply unpleasant and
very scary and because we thought well
we've got drugs now to treat this so
people don't need to be kept in these
asylums problem is though you let the
people out they stop taking the drugs
and they behave like crazy people
and then we not only indulge Mental
Illness but in recent years we've come
to to exalt it we've come to praise it
we've come to reward mental illness now
mental illness carries a cachet people
especially young people will will brag
about having a mental illness
it gives you some extra
intersectionality points well I'm not
black I'm not gay I'm not a Muslim I'm
not I don't have any of these well at
least I I'm mentally ill at least I can
say well I need to focus on my mental
health that's that's a phrase that
people use now as casual conversation
that would not have been the case even
10 years ago no one would have been
bragging about saying oh I've got a lot
of mental illnesses I say oh bro we got
to get you help
so so where do we go from here
until the conservatives are willing to
reassert
a sane Vision on society and willing to
wield political power to cultivate that
that sane
sensibility in society
until we reopen some insane asylums
until we put some restrictions on how
crazy people behave out in public until
we until we acknowledge and enforce
certain norms and standards like saying
boys or boys and girls or girls and if
you're a boy then you can't pretend to
be a girl in public that's weird stuff
and we're going to put you in
psychiatric treatment if you do that
until we start until we start wielding
that kind of political power
Dave Chappelle is going to get more eggs
in the face speaking of Psychiatry new
research there's a new study
you remember yesterday if you listen to
the show yesterday I talked about
Heather's there's so often new studies
that have the shocking news that our
Common Sense was right all along but
because we live in a scientistic age we
only believe things when they come in
studies and when they've got lots of
statistics and peer-reviewed clinical
numbers in them to tell us things that
we knew the whole time well here's the
new shocking study
anti-depressant drugs
can dull your emotions
this is the headline
antidepressant drugs do what they say
that they will do
they blunt your emotions
but not just in the good way not just in
the way that they're sold in the
commercials also in the bad way
they not only these drugs not only
make your depressive periods less severe
they also make your Joys less
exciting they make your your Joys less
joyful
quote emotional blunting is a common
side effect of SSRI antidepressants
according to Professor Barbara sahakian
at the University of Cambridge in a way
this may be in part how they work yeah
exactly they take away some of the
emotional pain that people who
experience depression feel but
unfortunately it seems that they also
take away some of the enjoyment
I hate these drugs
I don't have personal experience with
them I know that some people write in
they say antidepressant drugs were very
helpful to me or they saved my life I'm
not saying that there's no application
for them ever in any case
but for the vast majority of people who
are on these drugs right now and who are
on these drugs for a long period of time
it is a bad idea
and part of the reason
that people are are constantly being
prescribed these drugs
is because it's big money
antidepressants are a 17 billion dollar
a year industry they're set to grow to a
22 billion dollar per year industry by
2027. and here's here's how I know
that too many people are on these drugs
that probably most people on these drugs
should never touch these things
13 of American adults take
antidepressant drugs
13 percent
and when you just look at women
the number goes up to 18
one in five women in our country
regularly takes depression drugs
that is not here is a medical
intervention to maybe get you through a
particularly difficult period to then
allow psychological or religious
intervention to come in and help
ameliorate your problem no that is just
drug addiction
there is no way that it's just a fact of
the human condition that one in five
women needs to be on these insane
expensive powerful drugs that blunt your
experience of humanity that is a
national Scandal that is evil and it's
nothing new exactly
specifically with the women
for all of human history we have been
trying to cure women of Womanhood
there are all these interventions that
we've had to cure women of the
eccentricities that go along with being
women before we applied them all with
with zombie drugs we we went in and
scrambled up their brains we gave them
lobotomies in the middle of the 20th
century before that we had all sorts of
creative imaginative treatments for
hysteria
for for going back actually to the
ancient world
we're always trying to cure women of
being women
and now we're trying to cure Humanity of
any sense of suffering
but suffering is a sanctifying thing
and
if you
if you are constantly throughout your
whole life reliant on some very powerful
psychology altering drug mind altering
drug to deal with that something has
gone wrong and maybe there are even a
handful of people who really need that
kind of intervention you know it's a
Fallen World some people have really
severe problems
one in five Americans
no I don't think so I think that is a
national Scandal and the more we've
learned about big Pharma over the years
the the less and less likely I am to
give them the benefit of the doubt and
the more I hope Republicans start
pushing on this not just on the covet
vaccines but on this Scandal that we are
applying a fifth of the population
in in certain cases at least 13 percent
with very expensive powerful drugs to
take to deprive them of beautiful
aspects of their Humanity the rest of
the show continues now you don't want to
miss it because sometimes Mr Davies and
the producers over there they get very
very upset because they say I want you
to talk about this story I say I don't
know I don't want to talk about that
story what Michael you I want to hear
you talk about that Sam listen I got to
focus on important things I got to talk
about the sexy green Eminem okay I can't
I don't have time for it so they have
found a story that I've not gotten to
this week they they want my expert
opinion on it become a member right now
use code Knowles Canada wlas a checkout
for two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
all right